That's but regarding frequencies. Okay, I'm just
Remember I mentioned a while back that there's gonna be new
Breakthroughs coming through with the National Institute of Health
able to glean frequencies off the DNA
Different cancers and the DNA of different pathogens that are causative factors of cancer
Well that has now come to fruition and by next week
I will be able to update a lot of people's programs now if you're doing if you're using the right and
You're doing well and your cancers are really stable and you're doing great
You're gonna be kind of put on the backburner doing this whether we need to do it or not
But if your cancer's growing like in the case of this person
With the breast cancer cancer not growing, but we're not getting the results that we really want and you're gonna be put on the frontburner
Or anybody else that their cancer is not going in the right direction your PSA is going up or whatever we need to do
You're gonna be put on the frontburner of being updating your programs. So just know it won't be for another week or so
I will be getting access to all the NIH websites frequency sets
That we're going to be able to create some updates to your programs
So you may be getting a flash drive from being within the next two to three weeks
So if you get a flash drive, it'll give you will have the instructions
And I'll talk about this on the next Zoom call and I'll put it on the member site
So it'll have instructions on how to put it in your computer and to start running those frequencies
Now everybody right now has your program as a a
Sally Smith and it has a date after it. So some people that have been with me for years and years
I might not have the date after you're running the true right program and understand these NIH frequencies
I'm going to be able to use with the true right or the until and the artillery Robin now the artillery Robin is going to be more beneficial
Because we're going to be able to love the 11th harmonic with these frequencies. So
Either one they're going to be beneficial. So they're specific suite programs that I'm creating
From the NIH frequencies
So if I send you that flash drive then you'll start running that program. So to have a your name and then I have the date that I created the program and you'll start using that program still be
you know
A weekly program with some short programs and you could feel free to alternate between your old program and this new program
But we could talk about that at subsequent Zoom calls and I'll have information on the member site once and once those start going out
So that is to be real good news. Understand, you know
I promise to you when you started care here was not that it was going to cure your cancer. I don't have that capability. I'm not a
Healer God is your healer, but
God has given me wisdom. He's given me desire
Some people have called Maria and said you know, I don't want to start with Dr. Cutter's hold is he what is he going to retire?
Okay, I'm never retiring. Okay, unless God takes me out of here. So
My desire is to just continue to do everything I possibly can to help my patients get better
I don't have any magic bullets. I don't have any secret knowledge. I don't have any
Crystal ball
I rely on the Holy Spirit leading me to as many different things as I possibly can.
So when when I I knew technology anything that we could do to improve the care that we're already giving we're going to try to implement that
So I will let you know when these I'm super excited about these new frequencies
They're updated on a fairly regular basis by the National Institute of Health and
They're not right frequencies for the national Institute of Health. We're having to convert them. So they don't give
Right frequencies, but they get DNA mitochondrial frequencies that we convert to right frequencies to be able to create a program. So
It's very exciting information. It's just another thing that could possibly help a person get better. So I'll let you know when we're able to do that.